a question that has inspired computer
scientists for decades
is about
can we build machines that can program
themselves
now to answer that question in its
essence
we really need two aspects
first one is intelligence in other words
i would say artificial intelligence
ai
and the second ingredient needed is
for machines to be able to understand
their own language
i would say
code understanding
tourism to
result in the area that we are going to
dive deeper into today called ai
for code
now significant progress has been made
over last decade in artificial
intelligence itself
if i were to look at what were the major
foundational pillars
that resulted in those breakthrough
innovations which is percolating through
our society today they were
data
algorithms
and
very powerful compute hardware
when massive amount of data combined
with breakthrough innovation in
algorithms
combined with very fast computing
hardware
resulted in
tremendously powerful and large ai
models
which were able to understand seamlessly
human language
as we speak human language among each
other and understand each other machines
are now able to understand us as well
which resulted in machines to be able to
understand
the perceptual world around us the
visual world around us for us to be able
to build self-driving cars
and for machines to be able to
understand the textual documents that we
write as well
if i were to look at one pillar which
was most impor important among that
i would point out that will be data
in fact even among data
a particular data source has had a
pivotal role to play in this that data
source was called imagenet
it is said
that there is no ai without data and in
fact i would say
there wouldn't have been the latest
incarnation of ai without imagenet
this was a data set that had 14 million
images
and 22 000 classifications
this resulted in breakthroughs
in algorithms that we are reaping the
benefit of in other modalities as well
like natural language processing and
beyond
and we believe
that
the breakthroughs in natural language
processing can not only help us
understand human language but they
actually can help us understand machine
language as well in terms of machine
language understanding machine language
reasoning machine language
explainability and so on
so the question arises
what is needed for ai for code
and
same three pillars which were
foundational for progress in ai
will be needed for ai for code progress
as well
and then the second question arises what
is
our imagenet moment
and in fact
very recently we announced the imagenet
moment for
ai for code called codenet
coordinate has
just like imagenet
14 million code samples
in 55 different programming languages
and
to top it off
500 million or half a billion lines of
code
it's the
it's a massively large first of a kind
data set which is available to
researchers
and developers alike in open to be able
to make
massive progress in algorithms for ai
for code
to bring together these three pillars so
that we can accomplish tasks like
code language translation
code debugging
developers spend most of their time
not just writing code but most of the
time is spent debugging code
for machine to be able to generate new
code the nirvana is
imagine the scenario where rather than
you know people just leaning on
keyboards and typing these programs to
be able to build applications that we
utilize every day for us to be able to
talk to machines and they actually
generate the code automatically so code
generation
from natural language
code performance improvement
my code doesn't work as well can you
make recommendations to improve my
code's performance
code memory improvement
my code doesn't scale as well can you
make recommendations so that my code
scales much better
and finally
for us to be able to do code review
point out all the flaws in my code
suggest uh you know
functionality improvements and so on now
to be able to accomplish all of these
tasks which are critical to building
software systems which are now part of
every aspect of our society since
software has eaten the word already
we need to think about it in a very
organized way
and for that we have organized ourselves
in building a stack called ai for code
stack
ai for code stack
is comprised of multiple layers the
first layer as i said there is no ai
without data so the first layer is
actually the data layer itself
when we talk about data for ai for code
we are not just talking about source
code we actually are talking about
source code we are talking about
configuration files that are able to run
that code and deploy that code we are
talking about ingesting data sources
where just like developers are in on are
on some of these social media forums to
be able to
debug their problems to be able to get
help for their problems that they are
experiencing on a daily basis forums
like stack overflow like quera
if ai were to have a hope of
addressing these problems that i just
outlined it need to understand the
knowledge which has been gathered over
decades in solving those problems as
well by humans
so
source code is part of the data
configuration files are part of the data
and finally forums
are part of the data and many other data
sources
the next layer is what i'll describe as
ingestion layer
to be able to ingest all these
diversity of data sources and to be to
be able to
build a representation which can
actually correlate among the them to be
able to so that we can reason upon them
as well this is the data ingestion layer
which results in
[Music]
or which leads me to the next layer
which we call
intermediate representation layer
also known as ir layer
now ir layer is think about think of
this as
i take multitude of data sources i
correlate among them to this is think of
it as graph representation just like we
represent many other dependencies in our
world with graphs think about it like
those graph representations
so this is actually comprised of
graphs
now right above it
is a layer
think of this as
graph algorithms layer
with something called embeddings
embeddings are critical to converting
the intermediate representation into
numbers because computers can only deal
with numbers so the embeddings and graph
algorithms allow us to convert the
representations in ir into numbers so
that algorithms can work on them
and finally
we have the representation
a layer of ai algorithms now
also
known as
graph neural networks is one kind of
techniques in that and there are many
other techniques which
as i speak researchers are working on to
be able to build more and more powerful
ai for code techniques
and above that
our applications that we are building
and to build those applications there
are four major capabilities needed
for us to be able to understand code
for us to be able to retrieve and search
code
for us to be able to generate new code
just like the example i gave of natural
language and code getting generated and
for us to be able to test and verify
code
and these four capabilities these four
major capabilities
can be combined
to build applications for the real world
like
my code
has security flaws can ai help me
understand and identify those security
flaws automatically and fix them
so what we will call ai driven
vulnerability analysis
and other key applications
ai to be able to modernize my legacy
infrastructure
or legacy software systems
now
there were languages that were invented
decades back like cobol
which need to be modernized because the
skills for understanding and modernizing
those software systems have really gone
away but the need hasn't gone away at
all it's actually called a famous 100
billion dollar problem because there are
there are more than 100 billion lines of
cobalt code that exists and we need to
be able to modernize them into some of
the more recent languages like java and
others
it takes 50 cents a line to be able to
modernize it there lies your problem 50
200 billion dollars and a massive time
crunch in which we need to modernize
them ai to the rescue
ai for modernizing
legacy systems
ai to be able to
test
and debug my system
ai to be able to
generate new code
and build my applications
this stack
which we call ai for code stack
and the progress that we can make in
connecting data
through algorithms
and finally to compute hardware and
connect all of these three together to
give rise to
massive innovation
which will result in answering the
question that computer scientists have
pondered for for decades
can we build machines that can program
themselves and i think we are closer to
that reality than ever before and i'm
looking forward to the progress in this
area thank you
you